I have no vote on an enhanced curfew at  the Fremont Street Experience yesterday  the Las Vegas city council tabled a  decision on the proposal it would have  banned anyone under 21 years old from  that area between 9 pm and 5 a.m council  members pulled the ordinance because of  mainly criticism from the ACLU  it's pretty ridiculous I mean rarely do  we run into you know we often see dumb  proposals and we see separately  dangerous proposals but it's rare that  we get the combination of both dumb and  dangerous proposals built into one and  this is one of them  the enhanced curfew was first proposed  by mayor Carolyn Goodman for now the  city will just stick with the new  security measures on Fremont Street it  has right now including new metal  detectors but the city does Say it'll  bring back the idea of this curfew if  necessary